yo wassup Yoshi boy Q I want to welcome
you out back to musical dares the show
we play the classic game of musical
chairs with a daring twist may people
use some nasty bull we just have a good
time so let's get into this first round
hey guys I'm Chloe and as a kid I pretty
much roll musical chairs so I'm nervous
yo I'm Liz all I can say is that the
last musical chair competition I was in
I got first place so I'm ready for this
hi I'm jasmine and musical chair it's
taught me the quote it is not enough
that I succeed others shall fail
I'm Nate I'm pretty much an expert in
sitting in chairs sitting chairs all the
time think I'm gonna crush this one I'm
destiny and I came here to win
so good luck all right so that's our
cast
you guys know who's gonna be playing
let's get to our first row the rules of
musical dares are simple we have four
chairs three of the chairs are white and
one of the chairs is red the red chair
is the Dare chair if the music stops and
you land in the Dare chair or don't get
a chair at all you're either gonna be
eating some discussing or you'll be
heading home for the day winner gets one
hundred and fifty dollars cash or a
special grand prize
[Music]
quit them scary oh I want to top it on
the beat calm yourself oh well I'm kind
of seeing from Nate oh hey you gotta get
up it's about the bass ain't no case if
you got the bass alright so jazz destiny
Liz you guys are in the white ears you
guys are good to go
congratulation guys who unfortunately
you guys lost this round y'all gonna
have to eat some the both of us yeah
Chloe you let me know hey let me know go
take a look we got our is we got a
biscuit right here just some jelly some
sriracha a little bit of dressing on
there what kind of dress like Caesar
actually blue oh yeah I mean I'm gonna
eat it cuz I don't wanna lose oh well
this is saying less say look how much do
I have to eat take a bite take a big
bunch of big bite okay mmm get some of
that jelly oh god it's so hard
you couldn't even toast it for rude all
the stuff on it is about oh you're
getting into the Wayans I'm just gonna
do I mean justjust know Nate is here
Nate want this money
[Music]
Wow fireable offense that's horrible but
I've done it now so now I can stay thank
you
we'll listen we know Chloe is not
playing any games she's trying to get
this money
Nate I'm so sorry bro it was good to see
you here but I gotta ask you to go cuz
somebody gotta get this
cast today somebody got this cash today
by yo so unfortunately Nate had to get
up out of here he was a cool guy but in
this game you gotta be quick on your
feet so we got round two let's get into
a guys
[Music]
I like this one oh I like this one
[Applause]
people-people
if you got both say no then we have to
just drop down to final round Pete we
have some mashed potatoes gravy a piece
I'm uh I'm the failure
listen I think I physically can do it if
you can take a bite of that you're gonna
stick in this game you're gonna be still
eligible for that cash prize and we got
to give it away so let us know what you
want to do nah see a wing I see a wing
if we have that is a musical dares first
a double don't we're gonna have to
eliminate both of them we gotta go to
the last chair let's get it oh wait I
need a minute they're real I was
freaking out about potatoes you put
insects
all right so unfortunately last round
the first time in musical dares history
two people said absolutely not and I
fill them tbh but this round we're gonna
get right into the final round let's get
to it y'all right now I'm just saying
let it walk exploded
guess we got a little bounce with it
we're just following too closely this is
stressful
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm sorry okay it's whatever destiny
it's like you got into the chair but
you've got to do the Dare now so here's
the thing let's walk over here and see
to that going home we still got the
mashed potatoes with the Weaver ants in
there or you can take a bite of this cow
tongue and when you some money it's up
to you but just now Lizzie's right there
and she looked kind of hungry he let me
know somebody gotta win his cash um just
a bite you gotta take a bite to it and
swallow it
I'm shaking I don't know if you can see
that oh my god what musical games you
don't play just go for it just do it did
you do it from here it looks so thick
mmm chewy that's the need ah money talks
we're not playing no game destiny
congratulations okay Liz you look super
hungry and I knew you never did it but
destiny want this cash I'm gonna have to
ask you to go my initial strategy coming
into this was one to take off my shoes
because I did not come to play I needed
to move and I didn't need people
stepping on my wife Eli's okay and then
the final round my plan was to pull the
chair from under her that's where I was
gonna go luckily I just had a bigger
body well congratulations you are the
winner you know like if you want to take
me out well sweetie
[Music]